mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir voici d'abord notre sommet à
bruxelles à la demande de la france les
ministres de l'agriculture du neuf
prennent des mesures contre la baisse de
la viande bovine au stade de la
production crise du soja michel chevalet
fera le point washington nous faisons la
preuve qu'à la maison blanche depuis
deux ans on enregistrait sur
magnétophone toutes les conversations
téléphoniques du président nixon
les enquêteurs de l'affairé watergate
estime donc qu à l'aide des bandes
enregistrées
on devrait pouvoir enfin savoir si
monsieur nixon a donné des ordres pour
étouffer l'affairé watergate afghanistan
le roi est renversé par son beau frère
qui proclame la république à londres
débat houleux aux communes sur le voyage
officiel de monsieur caetano président
portugais dernière minute des relations
internationales le gouvernement
jordanien a décidé de rompre les
relations diplomatiques avec la tunisie
france taxe sur la police demandait aux
municipalités et bien une onzième ville
charleville mézières refuse
l'augmentation prévue par le nouveau
texte
l'ips un acheteur venant du koweït fait
une commande de 30 mille montre
résultats du baccalauréat en moyenne
deux tiers de reçues tour de france
ocaña toujours maillot jaune mais là je
pense que nous que je ne vous apprends
rien nous commencerons par bruxelles ces
instants du aujourd'hui thèmes
principaux mesures à prendre devant la
limitation par les etats-unis de leur
exportation de tourteaux de soja et
mesure prise à la demande de la france
dans le domaine de la viande de boeuf
joël françois dumont nous attendent à
bruxelles attention bruxelles à bout
depuis hier après-midi les neuf
ministres de la communauté essaie de
trouver une parade efficace à la
décision américaine de frappés d'embargo
leurs exportations de soja vers l'europe
un moment déjà où les européens ont à
faire face à une pénurie relative de
viande bovine privé les troupeaux de
leur alimentation de base qui le soja
riche en protéines de toutes sortes
s'il est condamné à produire eux-mêmes
cet oléagineux ou à trouver des aliments
de substitution en moins que les
européens ne comprennent une fois pour
toutes que washington entend régner en
maître
sur toutes les premières matière sur
toutes les matières premières mondiales
fusse-t-elle animales ou végétales à
cette première menace grave risque sans
ajouter une autre après le soja le maïs
demain encore d'autres produits et tout
ceci intervient comme par hasard au
moment où les européens doivent lors des
ventes négociations commerciales qui
doivent débuter à l'automne prochain
faire face aux etats-unis au japon et
bien la france par la bouche de monsieur
chirac ne l'entend pas ainsi
le ministre français de l'agriculture a
mis ses collègues en garde sur le soja
comme sur les céréales la viande bovine
et le sucre autant de produits de
première nécessité il les a même menacé
de quitter le conseil sont arrivés par
la fois un accord sur la viande bovine
c'est maintenant chose faite et sur des
mesures communes pour organiser une
meilleure autonomie agricole de l'europe
verte
pour cela il a produit dès son arrivée
un plan d'ensemble rappelant que depuis
plusieurs mois ici à bruxelles
il avait prévenu ses collègues de ce
danger aujourd'hui n'est pas encore trop
tard pour bien réagir mieux organisés
sur le plan international la production
et le commerce des produits alimentaires
le président pompidou l'a demandé le
mois dernier
voilà le fond du vrai problème qui
résolu serait de nature à favoriser une
meilleure coopération internationale
déjà la france aucune gagnent cause pour
contrôler les exportations de céréales
par la commission de bruxelles
maintenant un nouvel acteur vient
intervenir au plat viande bovine il n'en
reste pas moins qu'une action concertée
et immédiate doit être décidée
normalement aujourd'hui par les neuf
messieurs chirac qui vit maintenant par
plusieurs de ses collègues
et si encore de convaincre et de
rappeler que l'europe agricole en a
besoin pour sa survie
la crise du soja affecterait plus
particulièrement les exploitations dans
l'ouest de la france notamment celle de
la bretagne
car les ports sont entre autres très
friands de soja soja ou seguin l'année
l'autre se dit michel chevalet michel
monsieur rodgers ministre américain des
affaires étrangères a dit que si la
récolte de soja a perdu aux états unis
pour le mois d'octobre était
exceptionnelle les limitations des
exportations serait levé mais si la
récolte n'est pas exceptionnel on
revient à la situation actuelle
alors je voudrais vous demander si la
france peut produire du soja et si elle
peut on produire en quantité suffisante
pour notre détails
bien sûr cela le goûter le coeur du
problème la france produit du soja
mêlant produit seulement sur 400
hectares c'est vous dire très peu
et encore ces cultures n'est tels que
purement expérimental et se fait-elle
dans le sud-ouest et le sud-est de la
france
pourquoi et bien parce que le soja dont
je vous ai amené ici un exemplaire voilà
la graine du soja est bien le seul grain
du soja dont on tire de l'huile mais
aussi des tourteaux et bien cette graine
du soja exige des conditions climatiques
très particulière il lui faut notamment
beaucoup d'humilité beaucoup de chaleur
et elle se plaît très bien dans le
middle west lidl est des états unis
c'est à dire là où il n'ya si vous
voulez par deux demi saisons il n'y a
pas d'eau tonnes il n'y a pas de
printemps
ensuite il faut pas oublier que la
culture du soja ne peut pas être
mécanisées comme celle des autres
céréales enfin ce qui est encore en sa
défaveur
et bien la culture du soja à un très
faible rendement environ seulement le
quart de celle du maïs c'est vous dire
que la culture n'est pas très rentable
à l'heure actuelle peu les agriculteurs
alors existe-t-il des solutions de
remplacement
en attendant un miracle un miracle par
exemple des chercheurs de l'inra qui
pourrait nous trouver des hybrides
pouvant se développer en france on n'est
pas encore là alors une solution de
remplacement bien sûr tourner vers
d'autres graines des graines riches
aussi en protéines et en matières
grasses
les voici il ya tout d'abord le colza le
colza qui donne une très jolie couleur
jaune a nos chances une toute petite
graine fois plus grosse que des
lentilles ensuite le tournesol de
tournesol que vous connaissez
sous-nombre soleil est enfin si je
voudrais dire un outsider qui est pois
chiche qui est la féverole qui sera et
finalement l'aliment complet par
excellence
là vous avez devant vous si j'ose dire
le tiercé des protéines c'est-à-dire
colza tournesol et féveroles seulement
même en développant en intensifiant
cette culture ce qui donnerait pas tout
de suite des résultats et bien seulement
en 1982 couvrirait que le quart de nos
besoins et la chimie me direz vous et
bien les chimistes essaye de synthétiser
ses bottines il faudra le faire pour
toutes les autres pensent une solution
qui est très coûteuse reste un autre
espoir c'est d'avoir recours aux
microbes de faire travailler les
bactéries et cette poudre
cette poudre et bien ce sont des
protéines extraites des bactéries que
l'on cultive sur le pétrole est la seule
usine qui existent en france à lavéra ne
fournit seulement que 12000 tonnes
résumons-nous et bien pour remplacer le
soja n'y a pas de solution dans
l'immédiat
il y à une solution si j'ose dire moyen
terme qui est le colza et deux solutions
de cartes à jouer à long terme qui sont
le tournesol et la féverole merci michel
chevalet wagué tu es bien on dit qu'il y
à un coup de théâtre
en fait on a appris par un témoin que
l'on croyait avant de l'entendre seconde
est que dans la maison qu'à la maison
blanche on faisait enregistrée depuis
deux ans toutes les conversations
téléphoniques de monsieur nixon celle
qu'il donnait ou celle qu'il recevait je
voudrais préciser qu'il ne s'agissait
pas d' espionnage pour les conversations
tenues entre de tierces personnes
on ne mettait pas sur table d'écouté des
personnes étant ailleurs qu'à la maison
blanche
simplement monsieur nixon voulait
conserver pour ses archives personnelles
l'enregistrement intégral de ces
conversations
alors on estime à washington que
maintenant on pourrait avoir le fin mot
de l'affairé watergate
en écoutant les bandes enregistrées on
pourrait enfin savoir si oui ou non
monsieur nixon ignorait la sphère et
ignorait à tout le moins les efforts
faits pour l'étouffer
monsieur turf elle que l'on voit ici
déposé devant la commission d enquête
sur le scandale du watergate a provoqué
un véritable coup de théâtre en révélant
que les conversations du président nixon
était enregistré à la maison blanche les
sénateurs de commission denquête
l'information est d'importance car ces
sénateurs n'oublie pas que monsieur dean
le principal accusateur de monsieur
nixon a toujours été y ait ces
accusations en relatant des
conversations qu'il avait eues avec le
président nixon à la maison blanche si
ces conversations ont bien été
enregistrées on devrait pouvoir faire la
lumière sur l'euro ou ignorés dans le
salon dans get
mais ce soir la maison blanche vient de
faire savoir qu'elle ne communiquerait
passé l'enregistrement
mais comment fonctionne ce système d'
écoute c'est ce que nous dit depuis
washington
charles lambroschini l'enregistrement et
le magnétophone redémarre
ce même cassé comme en ce sens noté
avaient été intrigués est toujours
utilisée par le président à la maison
blanche et la salle où se réunissait le
conseil des min enfin le même
appareillage avait été installé dans la
retraite campagnarde du président
caméline comme des lidd notamment leonid
brejnev s'était reposé un week end pour
le confort de la maison blanche a refusé
de préciser les commotions d'ericsson
avec les 7 états étrangers avaient été
enregistrées un peu comme dans un film
policier
l'apparition du témoin surprise a donc
relancé le suspense en élevé depuis la
déposition des tonnes mais c'est
l'ancien ministre il semblait que la
dernière ligne de descendre la maison
blanche à lettonie maintenant tout à
fait changer le président refuse de
communiquer les enregistrements au sénat
et l'opinion risque de conclure la
culpabilité des prévenus temps tant que
selon les sondages plus de 70% des
américains pour déjà persuadé que nixon
était au courant de l'opération
décennale politique organisé par son
entourage
mais coup de théâtre est toujours
possible le contenu des bardes prétend
contraire confirmer la cause indique une
dépêche d'amman jordanie nous apprend
que le conseil des ministre jordanien a
décidé ce soir de rompre les relations
diplomatiques avec à tunis sans prendre
parti bien entendu sur les raisons qui
ont conduit le gouvernement dahmane à
cette initiative
nous voudrions repasser sur votre écran
un court extrait de l'interview que le
président tunisien a donné la semaine
dernière à christian brincourt et que
vous avez vu ici même dans l'extrait que
nous avons choisi le président bourguiba
parlait de la journée l'ouest ce qui
n'existe pas en réalité si la jordanie
où la transjordanie qui n'ont jamais
existé dans l'histoire transjordanie
jordanie ce séjour d'aspac leur une
invention de l'angleterre n'est ce pas
pour contenter pour consoler le prince
ligne abdallah et en faire un trône
quels amis n'est-ce pas pour faire du
royaume en transjordanie qu comme come
on come on peut dire que le transmit du
parti pour une grande pratique l'egypte
et on dit le transmis une seconde trans
aubrac la latence frati en réalité de
tout temps depuis l'antiquité depuis les
phillies maintien ça vient de définir un
mot palestine
il y à une palestine qui va des
frontières que les gîtes aux frontières
du cham cham c'est à dire la syrie liban
et la palestine qui est un pays qui a
été peuplée qui était connue depuis
l'antiquité mais jordan ihou l'attend
journalisme c'est une invention de
l'angleterre et la guerre des six jours
n'est ce pas un roi de jordanie actuel
où sont nés ses soeurs qui a décidé sans
le consentement des palestiniens
d'annexer la palestine comme les
israéliens ont annexé l'autre partie
finie que nous faut revenir à la réalité
a mérité ce qu'il y a une grande
promesse de palestine qui a été divisée
par l'onu pour accorder aux juifs un rom
national uni soleil sécurité à l'abri
des programmes pour crématoire des
humiliations qu'ils ont connue en europe
et surtout en europe centrale et
orientale mais jamais dans l'embarras à
londres l'opposition travailliste a
provoqué un débat d'urgence sur la
visite actuelle du premier ministre
portugais monsieur caetano angleterre
charles bruce sohn le numéro un du parti
travailliste ancien chef du gouvernement
britannique a été très sévère pour le
portugal dont il a dit je cite ici
monsieur wilson dont il a dit que son
mode de vie et paix le fascisme à
l'intérieur et le colonialisme agressif
à l'extérieur fin de citation de londres
une correspondance d'un readers des
traditions les communes ont cependant
aujourd'hui crée un précédent de taille
car c'est bien la première fois
mémoires de députés qu'on me critique
ouvertement la présence et la politique
d'un premier ministre étranger
précisément au moment où celui-ci est
l'invité du gouvernement vieux routier
de la politique et monsieur wilson le
chef de l'opposition travailliste a donc
remporté une double victoire d'abord en
obligeant monsieur issa accepter le
débat dans les circonstances actuelles
ensuite en aidant indirectement par un
esclandre parlementaire les mouvements
de libération du mozambique et de
l'angola
car en effet cela fait pour eux une
excellente publicité mais on reste
convaincu ici que monsieur wilson ne
fait pas tout cela pour les beaux yeux
des peuples africains
on est même persuadé que monsieur wilson
veut surtout ennuyé embarrassé monsieur
hills et en tirer profit sur le plan
intérieur
c'est donc avec le ton le plus indigné
que le ch milson devant les communes a
dénoncé la politique autoritaire de
monsieur caetano la répression des
troupes portugaise au mozambique et en
angola et surtout la violation par le
portugal des sanctions économiques
décidées contre la rhodésie du sud qui
est la nuit déclaré de la
grande-bretagne à la réponse pour
quelles raisons avez-vous donc reçu ici
le docteur caetano le porte-parole du
gouvernement n'a répondu tout simplement
à monsieur wilson qu'une alliance entre
les deux pays vieille de 600 ans était
très difficile à renier et l'on me
téléphoner pendant qu'un résident a été
surpris quand que la motion de
l'opposition travailliste à la chambre
des communes venait d'être rejeté
crise en afghanistan pendant que le roi
prenez les eaux son cousin lui a pris
son royaume que derrière il a transformé
en république
l'afghanistan est un pays d'asie située
entre l'iran l'urss la chine et le
pakistan superficie un peu plus grande
que la france population 16 millions le
roi le voici reçu avec une gamme palace
à londres il ya trois ans par elizabeth
d'angleterre et le prince philip pile
est remplacé à la tête de l'état
d'afghanistan par sardar mohammad daoud
son proche parent et ancien premier
ministre
lequel a déclaré en substance notre
économie était menacé de faillite et
nous n'étions jusqu'ici une pseudo
démocratie
relations internationales toujours
monsieur messmer part demain pour un
voyage officiel en hongrie le premier
que fera là bas un chef de gouvernement
français depuis la guerre selon les
endroits des contacts politiques et les
échanges culturels entre les deux pays
sont satisfaisants mais en matière
économique les relations selon budapest
pourrait être meilleur par exemple on y
souligne que la hongrie importe de
france pour une somme double de ce
qu'elle exporte chine un prêt budapest
monsieur messmer se rendra en bulgarie
et sera de retour samedi cement a besoin
sont chez lipp les ouvriers ont reçu une
très importante comme humble 30000
montre d'un commerçant déco avec lequel
se présenter ce matin à usine il
proposait de payer comptant en argent
liquide
dès la livraison le prix total soit 3
millions de francs actuels 300 millions
anciens une seule difficulté technique
toutes les montres doivent être pourvus
de bracelet métallique
les ouvriers de l'ip et udine moyens de
fournir ce qu'on leur demande onze
villes de france ont refusé de payer
l'augmentation des frais de police
d'après le code d'administrations
communales les villes devaient jusqu'à
présent versé une contribution de 2 %
aux dépenses que fait l'état pour la
police nationale
or ces dépenses augmentent et les
pouvoirs publics viennent de doubler la
vive contributions ce qui l'a porté à 4
% mais vous disais
les maires de 11 villes ne l'acceptent
daniel duigou ouvre le dossier depuis
1940 et une les villes d'au moins dix
mille habitants est libéré de la charge
financière de leur police municipale
après que celle ci ait été étatisé c'est
le ministère de l'intérieur qui en est
désormais responsable cependant d'après
l'article 115 du code administration des
communes
les municipalités doivent verser une
contribution aux dépenses de
fonctionnement et d'entretien des
services de la police nationale
en principe cette contribution s'élève à
25% des dépenses
en fait elle n'atteint que 2% ou plutôt
elle n'atteignait que de boer
puisque à la demande du premier ministre
et du ministre de l'économie et des
finances le ministre de l'intérieur
vient de doubler la contribution la
portant ainsi à 4%
cette mesure ne s'applique pas à la
ville de paris ainsi qu'au département
de sa banlieue
ils sont en effet les seuls en france à
participer entièrement aux 25% des
dépenses
en revanche cette mesure s'applique aux
autres villes mais dans 11 d'entre elles
des plus importantes ou le maire a
décidé de ne pas la respecter
j'ai refusé pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est que monsieur le préfet du
rhône la france mais par l'aide du 8
juin 1973 l'augmentation qui doublait le
contingent de police la charge de la
ville de diot et que j'ai reçu c'est
très flou 10 alors que mon budget est
voté
depuis le mois de janvier que je ne peux
pas le pari centimes à augmenter et
préfèrent payer aux contribuables
cette augmentation est d'autre part je
ne suis pas d'accord parce que depuis 25
ans le nombre égal à peillon et
l'agglomération et augmenter la
population de toulouse depuis 1945 a
doublé les problèmes de toute nature
sont survenus la circulation qui a
augmenté dans mes conditions
considérable les problèmes de sécurité
dans les grands ensembles
tout ceci fait que nous devrions avoir
un nombre de policiers sensiblement plus
importante hausse il était en 1945
or ce nom n'a pas augmenté il a même
légèrement diminué réaction du ministère
de l'intérieur
certes dans certains cas les services
urbains de la police sont insuffisants
en revanche d'après monsieur marcellin
il est faux de dire qu'au niveau global
aucun effort n'a été fait depuis 1968
plus de 15000 emplois nouveaux ont été
créés ce qui a coûté près de 800
millions de francs par an d'ailleurs le
budget de la police a doublé en cinq ans
il est actuellement de plus de trois
milliards et demi de francs
un retard de 20 ans devaient être
rattrapé le ministre a rappelé en effet
que sous la ivème mêmes sous la vème
république
les effectifs de la police n'ont pas été
augmentés alors que dans le même temps
l'urbanisation s'est considérablement
accrue entraînant une augmentation des
délits et des crimes
il est donc normal pour le ministre que
les communes participent à l'effort qui
a été développée depuis
d'autant que fait-on remarquer au
ministère la contribution de 2 % n'a pas
varié depuis plus de 20 ans une fois
doublé
elle demeure encore faible au total le
montant des contributions communales
s'élèvera à 48 millions de francs
elles seront sans doute compensé par un
supplément de recettes de 14 millions de
francs supplément correspondant au
relèvement des contraventions
il reste que la contribution communale
est obligatoire c'est dire que les
communes ne peuvent s'y soustraire sinon
le préfet du département pour al
inscrire d'office dans le budget des
communes
la réaction des maires apparaît donc de
pure forme elle est avant tout une
demande d'augmentation des effectifs de
la police urbaine transports la
compagnie aérienne allemande lufthansa
reprendra à partir de vendredi votre
prochain entre viven l'ensemble de ses
vols entre l'allemagne et la france
certaines liaisons avait été suspendu en
raison de la grève des aiguilleurs du
ciel allemand bachelot est bien le
pourcentage de réussite est comparable
cette année à celui de l'année dernière
environ 66% deux tiers nous vous avions
déjà donné des chiffres il ya quelques
jours quand il était officieux ils sont
maintenant officiel comme d'habitude
c'est un série a que le pourcentage
d'admis elle plus fort plus de 70 % et
en série des prime sciences agronomiques
et techniques qu'il est le plus faible
55 ans revenons-en à une tout autre
question
la pollution de la garonne à vous si
j'ose dire la gare ont quelques
milligrammes de cyanure par litre d'eau
et voici le résultat des centaines de
tonnes de poissons littéralement
foudroyé par le nuage toxique
il est probable que cette pollution est
accidentelle car un tel carnage n'avait
pas encore été observé sur la garonne
maladresse négligence l'enquète le dira
la région émettrice de cyanure et déjà
localisés le produit a été déversé dans
un petit affluent de la garonne en amont
de toulouse le cyanure suit son chemin
vers la mer et cela à la vitesse de 50
km par jour
on peut estimer que le nuage de cyanure
va se diluer dans l'eau au fil des
heures et que les dommages seront tout
de même moins important en aval de
toulouse
on se plaint toujours de l'encombrement
des ré il n'y a pas que les rues en fête
les trottoirs sont aussi de plus en plus
encombré l'association nationale des
droits du piéton est indigné de voir par
exemple autant de voitures et autant
d'appareils de signalisation prendre sur
le trottoir la place normalement réservé
à ceux qui marchent à pied l'association
a précisé aujourd'hui la manière dont
elles comptent agir à la rentrée pour
que ça marche mieux
mais d'abord qu'est ce que c'est
exactement quatre toiles trottoirs
chemin surélevé séparée de la chaussée
par une bordure et réservée à la
circulation des piétons
cette définition date de 1860
aujourd'hui elle mérite met un
complément tels que sert aussi parfois
d'aires de stationnement pour les
automobiles car depuis une ordonnance de
1966 les maires ont la possibilité
d'autoriser le stationnement des
voitures sur les trottoirs
l'association les droits du piéton
s'était pourvue devant le conseil d'état
contre cette tolérance le pourboire a
été roger cantin c'est parce que le
conseil d'état vient de prendre une
décision que nous qualifions de
stupéfiantes puisque il a accepté que l'
ordonnance du préfet de police soient
reconnus comme valable c'est à dire que
le stationnement soient tolérés sur les
trottoirs or le conseil d'état viennent
de reconnaître que le code de la route
ne pouvait pas admettre que il y à une
différenciation de trafic
le code de la route était de décret donc
nous allons voir si une loi n'est pas
possible ou contre battre cette décision
du conseil d'état
parce que pour le conseil d'état les
voitures peuvent se garer sur les
trottoirs
c'est à dire qu'elle considère que le
préfet de police les maires ont le droit
de tout faire ce que nous ne pouvons
admettre et nous opposons à cela l'arrêt
de la cour de cassation qui viennent de
rendre pénalement responsable un
automobiliste qui garées sur les
trottoirs avait causé la mort d'un
cycliste par suite d'un piéton qui avait
été obligée d'emprunter la chaussée donc
nous exprimons et qu'il y a
contradiction entre la cour de cassation
le conseil d'état mais sur les trottoirs
il n'y a pas que les voitures qui gêne
il ya aussi le mobilier urbain vous avez
cent fois raison et de ce côté-là les
handicapés les mères de famille les
aveugles ont des difficultés sur les
trottoirs et il n'ya plus tranquillité
tout ce qui s'adresse à l'automobile
panneaux d'interdiction parcmètres n'a
rien à faire sur les trottoirs il faut
remettre ça le long de la chaussée et
techniquement ce doit être possible
sport tour de france david remporte
l'étape de florence dans le cher mais
goliath ocaña conserve le maillot jaune
qui patricia et mener 6 blessés
aujourd'hui sur un glacier au dessus des
alpes d'huez
on a transporté patricia à lyon pour le
pire et le meilleur voeux de prompt
rétablissement
un grand peintre français dans un grand
musée de new york
jean dubuffet exposé ses oeuvres au
musée guggenheim
dessins peintures de dubuffet ouvrage en
trois dimensions vont remplir les salles
et cette vaste rétrospective va
traverser la mer et sera présentée au
grand palais de paris sur les champs
elysées pendant tout l'automne à partir
du 27 septembre
ainsi donc voici jean dubuffet très
officiellement consacrée par un hommage
que l'iran le musée guggenheim de new
york celui pour qui la culture est
asphyxiante celui pour qui l'art d'être
brut serait t'il récupérer dans un
système qui n'a cessé par son oeuvre et
ses idées de dénonce tout est là dans un
des plus beaux musées du monde de la
démarche artistique de jean dubuffet
l'une des plus surprenantes des plus
fécondes de ce temps lyall allées
marines est de la ville et de la
campagne les paysages grotesques les
matériaux logis les lieux cursif est
l'aboutissement de 40 ans de création
lourd loupe nouvelle vision du monde
jean dubuffet envahissant le nouveau
monde cela reste dans la plus grande des
logiques comme nul n'a jamais été
prophète dans son pays ce sont d'abord
les collectionneurs et marchands
américains qui se sont intéressés à cet
ancien marchand de vin converties sur le
tard à la pâte
c'est en septembre mieux vaut tard que
jamais qu'on pourra découvrir à paris au
grand palais que jean dubuffet est un
créateur immense qui dérange irrite
séduit et provoque la passion
les tableaux que vous voyez ici sans de
1944 c'est à dire le début de sa
carrière et ce qu'on voit à la fin de la
rétrospective leçon
le cn est il je pense qu'on peut dire ce
qui est particulier à leurs produits
c'est qu' après de développement
comprenant parlant c'est une série de
mutations
il ya beaucoup de variations dans son
oeuvre sa chance d'année en année et
mais on ne peut jamais dire qu'une chose
découle d'une autre très exactement
comme nous avons l'habitude de l'étudier
dans l'espoir de la présidente du buffet
s'est toujours intéressé à l'art des
fous alors aux graffitis contre
et alors justement de l'ami commun
et bien cette ravissante américaine par
un signal france à new york me conduit à
terminer cette édition avoir comptant
une histoire je voudrais vous dire que
dans une localité assez importante de
californie n'a pas la brigade
ultramoderne des sapeurs pompiers
comptent désormais neuf dames
je les félicite pour ce nouveau pas sur
le chemin de l'égalité mais les dépêches
nous disent que ces dames sont toutes
les 9 port joli
alors je me demande si les messieurs de
la ville ne vont pas brûler d'amour pour
elle et si elles parviendront ces dames
à éteindre
comme il faut la flamme qu'elles auront
à lui mais dans les coeurs masculin
les paris sont ouverts et hamza
messieurs notre édition est terminée je
vous souhaite une très bonne soirée